we have brand new news on the upcoming
iPhone 15 lineup with bad news on the
standard 15 and it looks like it's going
to be even more limited compared to the
Pro Models but on the flip side we do
have some positive news as well as you
know everybody has been talking about
usb type c coming to the iPhones ever
since the EU passed a law that is going
to force Apple to standardize with an
Universal connector instead of using
lightning and recently Greg Wozniak said
the Apple will be forced to comply with
this upcoming news now you guys saw my
video where I said I did not want USB
type c coming to the iPhone if apple is
going to do the same thing that it's
doing to other devices where they are
drastically limiting it to Tech that
came out almost 23 years ago now USB
type-c is great but I don't want a
connector that's gonna be 10 times
slower than a 2015 iPad so I sit in and
won it and apple actually had up to the
end of 2024 to switch over but now mean
Shake quo gave us some additional
information now there are other Tech
reviewers that agreed the Apple doesn't
have to use USB type c they could go
portless but now it looks like India is
putting out a similar Law to force Apple
to go with USB type c now Michiko has
been saying that Apple will be switching
to USB type c and doing it next year on
the iPhone 15 light up but previously he
said that maybe it won't be all of the
models but he just gave us a brand new
leak saying that yes all of the models
are going to have USB type c but Apple
will be limiting the iPhone 15s to USB
2.0 speeds which is what we have on the
lightning iPhones today it is incredibly
slow to transfer or to back up and that
is what I did not want because that is
just a limitation that should not be
there and once again the iPad 10s that
came out even though it's using the same
chassis and the same chip as the iPad
Air 4 they also limited to USB 2.0 which
may transfers extremely slow now on the
plus side he also said that the Pro
Models will have a faster transfer
speeds which is amazing news for all of
us that are shooting these Pro raw files
with their iPhones and they want to back
up and transfer files but that also
means that you will have to spend more
money on the Pro Models if you want to
get that speed now what he said in
particular is that it could have either
USB 3.2 which could be 20 gigabit per
second or what I personally want
Thunderbolt because that goes up to 40
gigabit per second and that stands out
from all the other phones on the market
so Apple's gonna go from having
extremely slow low transfers and way
slower than a Samsung phone to something
that is incredibly fast now we don't yet
know what exactly it is going to have
but Apple could even try to
differentiate the regular 15 pro model
with the pro Max or the Pro Ultra if
they're going to call it that and give
the ultra one the Thunderbolt and try to
get you to spend even more money now
personally I agree with many commenters
that are saying that we should not have
USB 2 in 2022 let alone 2023 and it is
purely a marketing play but I also
understand Apple wanting to
differentiate it I just think there are
other ways and unfortunately even now
the iPhone 14s are not great and that is
why the sales of the regular models have
plummeted and the sales of the pros
especially the pro Maxes have shot up so
much because if people are going to
upgrade and get a new iPhone they want
to have uh the best features the new
cameras the new Dynamic Island that is
included and that is how people are
voting with their wallets which is
exactly what Tim Cook wants and that
plan is working extremely well because
the iPhone 14 Pro Models if you order
one right now it is unlikely to arrive
in time for Christmas which is more than
a month away so if we take a look at the
order right here it says it will arrive
December 28th at the earliest if you
order it today but if you look at the
regular iPhone 14 it can arrive tomorrow
by 5 PM and the same thing for the 14
plus which is a brand new model it's the
first time that apple is giving you a
lower price large iPhone and that plan
is not working at least nobody is buying
it so much so the Apple shutdown
production of that phone because they
have too many of them in stock where
they didn't even do that with the iPhone
13 mini they lowered production but they
did not shut it down so what else will
Apple give to the Pro Models to get
people to want to spend more money than
the regular 15s and why would you not
want to buy that well the first thing is
the new Periscope camera which is going
to have a six times optical zoom that is
just going to come and potentially to
only the max model of the larger one and
that's going to push even more people to
buy that model along with the
Thunderbolt of course we have Pro motion
which is really nice and we have that
always on display as well which even
though it does drain battery and I
showed you guys how you guys could save
battery people still want to have that
and apple they're listening to people's
feedback which is why the latest version
of iOS 16.2 beta apple is now allowing
you to disable the wallpaper and
notifications for that always on display
to make it a lot cleaner just like with
Android and of course course that uses
less power so if people want to do that
by themselves Apple's listening and
they're giving us that now I think one
of the best things about the iPhone 14
is that 48 megapixel camera uh the
photos are way better when you're using
Pro raw unfortunately you can't shoot in
JPEG but maybe if people keep pushing
Apple they'll give us that ability and
of course we had lots of talk about AK
which did not come to the iPhone 14 Pros
but that is something that should be
coming to the iPhone 15 pros and pro
Max's because the sensor is capable of
giving us that so with all those extra
features a lot more people are going to
want to spend the extra money and the
regular 15 even though we are supposed
to get a redesign on there and
potentially even the dynamic Island when
you have price points that are so close
and all these extra features and not
having those limitations on the regular
one like those USB 2.0 speeds that is
going to make even more people want to
spend the extra money and that is
exactly what Apple wants right now to
kick up the the amount of money that
they're making and where we can clearly
see that by their actions especially now
we have the report of Apple employees
internally being unhappy with Apple's
new plans to show a lot more ads to
iPhone users even though their services
department is making so much money last
year they made 10 billion more than the
year before they're trying to ramp all
of that up because in these tough times
people advertising is going down we're
doing more dedicated ads as well before
our advertising goes way down a lot of
YouTubers are going to be affected and
apple is gearing up for that as well so
what do you guys think about Apple still
using USB 2.0 with the USB type-c port
at least on the base models are you guys
okay with that is that fine or uh do you
guys think that Apple should be giving
us at least USB 3.05 gigabit on those
lower phones and is that an enough to
push you to spend more on the pro or Pro
Max or do you not really care about it
let us know down in the comment section
below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there that's been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]